[Musique]
après le 11 septembre on avait peur de
tous les avions pu être détourné que ça
puisse se reproduire
j'étais en doctorat depuis 24 heures
quand j'ai toutes mes yeux levés en
sécurité nationale bonjour dame madame
la sénatrice
vous avez lu l'article dans le new york
times il apparaît que la cia a détruit d
enregistrement des interrogatoires de
détenus al qaïda je veux donc savoir ce
que contenaient ces enregistrements et
pourquoi on les a détruits née le papier
le papier ça cause plein de problèmes de
notre maison dans notre maison à nous le
papier permet de se rappeler hier soir
je trouve ceci ce sera le dernier numéro
vous l'avez déjà utilisé cette
apparaître on a vu des vidéos
cet homme a subi la baignoire 183 fois
tout ce que ksm leur a fournis étaient
soit un mensonge soit une information
déjà quand
si sa fonction pourquoi doit-on il
retenait 183 fois publier ce rapport
provoquera peut-être une prise de
conscience je suis en désaccord complet
avec l'histoire que vous essayez de vous
raconter les états unis ne recourent pas
la torture
fait pas n'importe quoi daniel
ne peuvent pas détruire le document se
rabat sur le second choix vous
tant d'avoir sauvé des vies ils n'ont
réussi qu'à rendre impossible de
poursuivre un des pires criminels de
guerre parce que si son affaire été
dévoilée par un de ses avocats il ya un
monde où d'office ce type a organisé le
11-septembre est hors de question de
permettre au pouvoir exécutif de nouveau
accueillir du renseignement de sauver
des vies américaines histoire est écrite
par les vainqueurs change notre approche
vous avez vu leurs études rien n'est
plus loin de la vérité démocratie ses
pointes à la s'il y en avait votre
rapport on le publierai demain non si ça
va sortir faut que ça sorte comme il
faut